Hello, everyone.
Welcome to this talk
on implementing
informed consent with
knowledge graphs.
My name is Anelioa Kurteva,
and I'm a PhD researcher at
the Semantic
Technology Institute
at the University
of Innsbruck.
Currently, I am interested in
my PhD in knowledge graphs,
the semantic web
privacy, GDPR,
and human computer
interaction,
and how they can work together
to solve issues such
as, consent in,
different domains.
So let's begin.
A bit of
background information
on GDPR first. So GDPR became
applicable in May of twenty
eighteen in all member states
to harmonize data
privacy laws across,
Europe. GDPR's main aim is to
give control to
individuals over
their personal data,
and it introduced
the notion of
informed consent.
And, also, GDPR views consent
as one of its legal basis for
data processing.
But, of course,
there are hefty fines for not
being compliant with GDPR.
Up to ten million
or two percent,
of the firm's worldwide
annual revenue.
So what is consent
according to GDPR?
So consent according
to article
four of GDPR is
any freely given,
specific, informed,
and unambiguous
indication, of the data,
subject agreement
to the processing
of personal data
related to him or her.
And to be more specific,
what is exactly
informed consent?
So before the data subjects
grant consent, they
should be married,
aware of information
such as who
who is the data controller,
what kind of data
will be used,
for what purposes is
the data required,
how the data will be used,
how the data will
be processed,
where the data
will be stored,
with whom will be shared.
And, of course,
much more information that can
be provided here
to individuals
so they're more informed.
So here come two projects that
I'm currently working on and
that also consider,
GDPR and consent.
We have the company, project,
whose goal, is to,
develop an open platform on
which private and public
institutions can
create different
campaigns. And a campaigning
company is a specific request
for a data from
individuals, and,
that data will be analyzed.
The main focus for
now is vehicle
sensor data, and, actually,
company runs in
Hanover, Germany.
And the second project
is the Smashfit
project whose goal
is to establish
a framework, for secure and
trusted sharing of,
personal data and industrial
data streams across
different silos and,
smart cities, for example,
which I'll talk a bit a bit,
further in the presentation.
And, yes, consent
in smart cities.
So in a smart city,
consent is,
consent and also the data of
the individuals can be spread
across multiple
different zeroes,
which are databases,
locations,
people, and can be used for
different purposes
by different
entities simultaneously.
Here on the side,
you can see,
smart city domains.
We have smart retail,
smart mobility,
smart health,
smart government,
education, smart homes.
And, the other goal is to
implement the consent,
in a way that does
not distribute
the data flow between those
silos while still
being compliant
with GDPR. And
consent in smart
cities is actually one of,
the use cases that inspired
the smart chip project,
which you can also
have a look at.
So the main challenges that
we've identified are,
responsibilities.
Who is responsible for what?
Who records
the consent? Storage.
Where is the consent stored?
What privacy and security
mechanisms are in place?
Who has access to the consent
and also to the data?
And can the consent
decision of
the individual be
changed without the,
his knowledge? Also,
what are the implications of
revoking consent?
How can a user revoke
their consent?
And what happens
to the data and
the processes that,
use the consent
after the consent
is revoked?
And finally, awareness,
awareness of what it means to
give consent and
the implications
that follow.
Some knowledge graphs,
which I'm sure most
of you are aware of,
they can be used as
a consent solution,
and they have many
benefits that
can be related to
consent, but,
of course, are not limited.
For example, knowledge graph
provide transparency because
data is bought in
human readable
and machine readable formats.
They provide traceability,
which when it
comes to consent,
is really, crucial because,
it provides provenance,
information.
We can use different,
ontologies for
provenance events
and time stamp, data.
So we preserve
the records of consent,
when the consent
decision was made,
when it was changed,
and more.
We have also
knowledge discovery.
We can discover
different patterns
and consistencies,
security and privacy issues.
We can perform reasoning on
knowledge graphs,
which is especially useful for
GDPR compliance checking.
We can understand connections
between data. For example,
how a third party gain access
to specific user data.
And, of course,
knowledge graphs
provide a common
understanding
across all entities
in the smart cities
of the notion
of consent and
many more concepts
that exist in the domain.
So we performed a survey,
which you can check to have,
input to the reference
on semantic
models for consent.
And, of course,
work has been done
through the years,
and several
ontologies exist as
you can see. However,
we've identified
common limitations.
There these
ontologies are either
too general because,
they're part of project,
and these projects have their
own use cases. And
this the ontologies
also focus only on
these, use cases.
The ontologies, yes,
they represent only
consent sometimes,
which, means that no other
information about
the data itself,
or the processing
that's applied
to the data is modeled.
And, some of the ontologies,
do not model
consent state state
changes such as
revoked, withdrawn,
etcetera. And,
most of the ontologies are not
open access, which
can complicate
their reuse.
Current goals of,
the projects that
I presented,
Kompano and, SmashIt,
is to implement the life cycle
of informed consent
with knowledge
graphs. And when we
say life cycle,
we view,
here on the side the different
steps that can be undertaken
when dealing with consent.
We have the request
of consent,
the comprehension of consent,
the decision about consent,
and the use of consent.
And all of these,
stages also consists,
of, different sub
steps that can
be taken, different,
tools and approaches that can
be adopted when it comes to
the management of
consent at each stage.
And the next goal is to raise
the awareness about what it
means to give consent
and the implications
that follow.
So the first step that we took
is to model a sample,
a campaign in
the company or project.
The campaign is called,
and it's actually
a real campaign
that was run by the Tyrolian
government here in Austria,
a couple of years ago.
The main date of interest in
that campaign was to,
GPS data from car drivers in
the area of Innsbruck up to
fifteen kilometers away,
and the data was
stored anonymously
in a central database
in Kuchstein
or by owned by
the government.
Upon the user, consent,
the data was,
or will be also, up to today,
shared with, STI Innsbruck,
which is my research group,
and we run different
processing connect.
So based on that
simple campaign,
we created our, main
ontology and then,
we added data and
created the the
knowledge graph, which
you can see here.
It's quite simple
and represents
currently only one campaign.
Rosa Finn's book has
presented earlier,
and we have the different data
associated with it
when the consent
was asked. So we
have the status
of consent, which is, given.
We have the duration
of campaign,
twelve days. We have
the main purpose,
which is for fraud detection.
We have also who
requested the campaign,
which is the Innsbruck
government.
We have the type of
data, GPS data,
and, of course,
the person who gave
their consent.
And while this
data is really,
easy to understand by machines
and experts both in
human readable,
machine readable format.
How can individuals with no
knowledge of linked
data understand
this, model?
So we decided to
visualize the consent
first, and,
we began by analyzing existing
consent request
user interfaces.
Some of the issues that,
we came across are
information overload,
privacy and policy privacy
policies written in technical
and legal jargon.
As you can see
here on the side,
we have long documents and
legalese that people rarely
understand and read.
We have consent requests which
are which are not
really compliant
with GDPR because no
information about,
the consent is presented.
For example, why is
the data required?
Why is the data,
what is the purpose
of the data,
how data will be processed,
where where the data
will be stored,
and more. And, also,
these user interfaces,
do not clearly indicate that
the individuals
have the right to,
revoke their consent,
which is also
known as the right
to be forgotten.
So we, created,
a simple user interface for
the company or project,
which displays
the different campaigns,
which you can see
on the side.
Or it you can see
campaigns from
different companies.
The UI was developed with,
Google's new UI toolkit
called Flutter,
and it follows the,
consent knowledge
graph which we,
shown before.
And the UI is designed to be
used in vehicles,
for example,
on tablet or a phone
by the individual.
Here, you can see more details
about the actual
campaign the details
when the user
selects the campaign
by by, Volkswagen.
You can see the,
company name,
the campaign, roads
of Innsbruck,
what data will be collected,
when is the start date,
the end date of the campaign.
And further, when
the user selects
to agree to
participate in that
campaign, we
present them with,
preference, lists.
So the user can select really
if they want to share all of
their data that's asked
for or only GPS,
tire pressure, speed,
and then finalize
their consent.
But then, we were,
thinking of how
to even further,
help raise the awareness
of individuals.
So we decided to focus on
visualizing of,
what happens after
the consent is given.
And for that, we use, again,
the knowledge graph which we
have with
the different campaigns
as the main source
of information
and the d three,
visualization library.
And, we actually
published a paper
in June this year.
You can, have a look if you're
more interested,
which focuses exactly
on this topic.
So we presented
individuals, with,
this, user interface.
In the middle,
you can see this
is the vehicle from which,
the data is transmitted
or the individual
itself inside of the vehicle,
and we have the different
campaigns that
these individuals
participates in.
For example, green
future, drive smart,
highway zero,
and each campaign
is associated
with, different,
types of data.
And we use color blocking to
identify that. For example,
speed is in yellow,
GPS is in purple,
and we have also a team change
from light to dark.
You can actually test the user
interface, here and play with
it for yourself,
see if you like it,
and maybe you can even,
provide some feedback about,
future improvements
that can be
done to it. So when
the individual
selects a campaign,
for example,
green future,
they're presented
with a bit more detailed,
information about
this campaign.
Specifically, what
type of data was,
retrieved at what time and by
which company.
We performed some
user evaluation.
We had twenty five
participants,
female and, male,
age eighteen to,
fifty five, with different
university degrees,
and eighty percent of them had
a driving license.
Evaluation details
you can find
in the paper.
So, we asked
the same questions
about consent
before presenting
the individuals with
the UI and after.
So, before,
we asked them if
they're willing
to share their
GPS location and
other types of data
with companies,
and most of them
said that probably,
not and never they would share
such data. And
after we presented
them with a visualization of
what happens to their,
data after consent is given,
most of them actually changed
their opinion and
said that possibly,
they would if they
had this, tool.
Next, we asked them to,
describe the interface
with some
keywords. They said
it's organized,
effective, innovative.
We also evaluated
the comprehension
of individuals.
We asked them if
they can easily
see what's happening to their
data at specific times,
and most of the individuals
strongly agreed and agreed.
And, when asked if the graph
helped them understand what
happens to their data,
most individuals,
again, agreed and
strongly agreed.
So the main takeaways from our
evaluation are
that visualizations
help increase
the comprehension
of what it means to
give consent and,
trust of the users.
And that,
the application
that we created
creates more transparency,
the data sharing process.
Here are just some
examples of,
future things that,
I think are also important to
want to consider.
For example, consent standard
standardization. I think that
the W3C consent
community group
is currently working
towards different,
and better solutions
for consent
so you can have a look there.
Also, what happens,
beyond GDPR because
GDPR, yes,
it's a a really
huge law, but,
in some places, it
does not apply.
In California, for example,
we have the CCPA,
and other countries have their
own laws about consent.
And when in some cases,
consent might not be enough,
and what happens then?
Maybe contracts
and licenses can
come into play.
So these are just some things
that we can all think about.
And if you have
any suggestions
or you want to discuss,
feel free to reach
out and send
me an email or even
here in the chat.
So So thank you very much for
your attention,
and I'll take any
questions now
if you have.